live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney host of the Dr John deloney show
number one best-selling author of The
Fabulous book own your past change your
future I was trying to remember it there
for a second Breaking Me Down open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's start with
Nick and Sacramento this hour hey Nick
how are you
I'm doing great how are you doing better
than I deserve what's up
uh such an honor to talk to you um we
actually came into our debt-free screen
back in uh 2017 and uh you've definitely
changed their life so thank you well
thank you you changed your life we just
showed you how proud of you
on Monday that I am being laid off as of
next Friday awesome and yeah
um so we only have our mortgage
obviously because we're debt free
um and I'm getting uh 12 weeks of
severance so that's good yes
um and I've been with the company 19
years
so I was just I had transferred out to
California from Buffalo seven years ago
and the guy that had recruited me here
he um is in a different state he's out
in Colorado and he's asked me if I
wanted to move out there for a position
fun and I'm trying to what do you do
decide if that's a good move I'm a
manager and sales so it would be a sales
position so what do you make now
77. cool so how much more is he going to
pay in Colorado
uh he said his lowest paid employee
makes Commission of about 110 and I'm
more I'm they're not half the
salesperson I am
so you're gonna be sales or sales
manager
tails okay
all right and does he have a base
no there is no base
is it selling the same kind of thing
you're selling now
no it's a totally different product
what part of Colorado
Thunder okay well Denver's a great City
um yeah it is and we have family there
we have a brother there but
um we had moved here because my wife's
parents and sister and all the rest of
the family is here
how long is it going to take you to get
a book of business up and going
is he gonna hand you a client list or is
he gonna just point you to the door and
say go get them
yeah the leads are generated
how long before you start making money
dude
um it would be eight weeks of training
he said
and then I'd be pretty much on my own
eight weeks of training with no pay
no a-week's obtaining um with 800 a week
so they have a training pay okay all
right what are you selling what would be
you'd be selling in Denver
HVAC
okay
um
okay uh there's nothing here that sounds
bad except a straight commission part
and the part where uh you go out with
the first girl that says you look good
right after your divorce that's why I
wouldn't do it but that's just me
you went into it 19 years and you got
kicked in the teeth and the first guy
the first person that looks at you and
says you're handsome you go running that
scares me
okay uh so I want you to do some more
shopping comparative shopping as to what
you're worth in the marketplace I'm
guessing the reason I said awesome is
when you've been in a job 19 years it's
It's Not Unusual at all for you to get a
job making more when you leave there you
have 12 weeks to do that and end up with
a net signing bonus because your
Severance turns into a signing bonus if
you go and get employed now
and they laid you off last Friday with
no notice
uh they laid me off uh Monday and I'm
employed until next Friday oh okay okay
so two weeks notice yep so I'll get my
12 weeks seven five weeks of old
vacation time plus these two weeks that
I'm working okay all right so the the
equivalent of nine of 18 weeks
yes yeah okay cool well that's a lot of
time for you to land on your feet making
more than you used to make if you want
to leave Sacramento it doesn't sound
like you're tied up there or anything
and Denver's fine I'm not down on Denver
and I don't necessarily hate the job
it's just that you haven't really looked
at anything else
and I think you take a week or two here
and just see what you're worth in the
marketplace you might be really
pleasantly surprised that somebody
offers you 100 and a quarter base with
an upside of 200.
that'd be pretty cool
and that would be awesome do the
you're worth more than just following a
job around and what I mean by that is
take a minute and you've been doing the
same thing for two decades take a minute
just to say hey what do I want my life
to look like in five or ten years where
do I want to be
what I want to be doing what's your why
are you married you should
yes Sam what's she saying about all this
um she is very confused and because
she's a teacher and she's credentialed
but she has to clear a credential and
that's California and then have to
transfer everything to Colorado it would
be a hassle
so transferred anywhere would be a
hassle yeah but maybe the conversation
is sitting down with her and saying okay
you and I we have a Magic Moment
somebody pushed us off a cliff not great
but we have a long a nice parachute
before we hit the ground what do we want
to do do you want to stay in California
she might tell you I really want to stay
here
um but it's hard when a husband just got
just got his legs knocked out from under
him he comes home and says all right I
found a new job pack it up we're going
to Colorado it's hard for somebody to
put up a roadblock in that in that
scenario right because she knows you're
hurting she knows you feel abandoned
like these guys betrayed betrayed you
yeah and so she's not going to say no
unless you ask right so sit down and say
hey what do we want this to look like
take her on a nice dinner how old are
you
I am 40 41 uh two weeks so ask yourself
what do you want to be doing when you're
61.
and let's aim at that and then ask
yourself what has to be true for me to
be doing that when I'm 61 and where do I
want to be doing it because you followed
the job to Sacramento so you're in
Sacramento by default not by plan so you
have an opportunity here to reset and
actually plan where you want to be so
tail wagging the dog not where they drag
you to there you go you don't have to
corporate Gypsy you can get to pick I
pick ta-da wherever I want to live and
you may want to go someplace you know I
don't know but and they may sit down and
say it'll be awesome to go have an
adventure in Denver that'd be great now
there's nothing wrong with that you may
Circle back to that but I wouldn't pick
it when it's your only option on the
table
I would put like five other options on
the table and make that Denver deal rise
to the top I might also ask Denver Bubba
to cover my base for a while if he Oh no
you're easy you're easily the best
salesman that I've ever seen well then
you gotta you know it's an 80 base and
um you know I got to earn through that
it's a draw I gotta run through it uh
you know put your money where your mouth
is if you think I'm such a stud and I
need I need some help getting here too
yeah right whatever whatever you need
yeah well exactly and uh so yeah I yeah
yeah let's uh let's do that that's I
want some more options I don't want you
to take eight weeks over analyzing this
I want you to take eight days and I want
you to go on five job interviews by Zoom
or otherwise I want you out there poking
around finding what is out there Nick
you're probably going to be surprised in
this current environment where there is
a labor shortage
that you are worth more than you are
being paid at the other place and they
did you a favor that's why when you said
I got laid off I said awesome
it probably means an awesome new
adventure and more pay if you'll mess
with this just a little bit Hang on
we're going to send you Ken Coleman's uh
gut clear assessment for free in his new
book number one bestseller paycheck to
purpose all of that you definitely need
to read in the next 24 48 hours this
there's the Ramsay show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see a chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number here
triple eight eight two five five two two
five John these questions for humans
cards are an unbelievable Blockbuster
hit
we can't keep them in the store it's
wild huh
it's crazy yeah yeah um
so here's the thing man you have those
moments when you're sitting next to
somebody and you feel a thousand miles
apart from them
I used to think that was a character
issue or you weren't a good dad or a
good no I just realized it's we we've
just grown up in a generation we don't
have those skills and some of y'all are
feeling that you're a thousand miles
away from people that you care about
right now so we got to put on our phones
we've substituted deep God's sakes and
put down our phone meaningful
conversations for Netflix and scrolling
you deserve better relationships and
that means having better conversations
and that's why we created questions for
humans these are conversation starters
that will help you disconnect from your
screens and actually connect and have
fun with people you care about there's a
deck for everyone dating couples girls
night by the way we got some
extraordinary brilliant women to do
girls night it's not just me and my
buddies sit in a room thinking this
would be hilarious guys night parents
and kids friends editions and more
they've been flying off the shelves and
all these will get you spending time
laughing together learning something
unexpected pick up one two or all of our
questions for human starters and have
fun together you can go to
ramseysolutions.com humans
it's possible that there is no human
harder to talk to than a teenage child
it's very difficult it's very difficult
so having a having a deck of cards that
you just pulling out and you ask a
question and before you know it
everybody's laughing and telling stories
and uh admitting to things they
shouldn't and everything else yeah it's
uh it's pretty crazy and what's been fun
is I when these cards were first coming
out I would test them on my own kids and
my son was finishing fifth grade
entering into sixth grade and now he's
almost through seventh grade and his
answers to the same questions are
different now and it's been fun it's
been cool and uh we're they're all
they're growing with us and so anyway
I'm loving it I use them in my house is
all is is the best uh advertisement I
could give for him yeah and we can't
keep them I mean we order them and they
just go out of here like crazy so
ramseysolutions.com
humans questions for humans cards in the
store at ramsaysolutions.com be sure and
check them out Tina's in Fort Lauderdale
hi Tina how are you
hi guys I appreciate your show I'm good
thanks
um my my question is around
um using a HELOC to put 20 down on a new
home nope and then selling the current
home right after closing on the new home
oh that home
I got confused okay yeah so you're going
to close on you're going to close on
another property before yours closes
I I would like to so that's pretty
dangerous I just yeah okay what happens
if it doesn't close you got two house
payments and you know what you become
after that we call them a motivated
seller who sells their house cheap
because they get stuck
three times that happened to me whoa
You're Gonna Learn after the first one
no no three times I have gone to closing
or within a week of closing the deal has
fallen through oh when I'm trying to
sell a property oh yeah yeah I see okay
and yeah we're gonna close on the second
one after the first one closes
then we use I just did that I just did
that I am in my second real estate
property now
um and when I sold the first home to get
into this new home that I live in now
um it was really stressful for me to not
have anywhere to live like in the
interim I happen to just you know what's
more stressful two house payments yeah
how long of a gap are you talking here
um I mean I would immediately
like I guess my idea of doing it that
way is because you know I
um this closing on this new this is
the sale that I did just now it was
really stressful for me to move I was I
need to find a home where am I gonna
live
um you know and I would have preferred
to be able to secure a home for me first
um so okay so write a contract on the
other on the property you're purchasing
contingent on the sale of yours and set
the closings up on the same day
but if yours doesn't if your current
house doesn't close you don't close on
the new one
because you're going to end up with two
house payments in a market that is
slowed down with higher interest rates
and uh you're gonna be calling me two
years from now going I've done the
Thomas thing I got two house payments
that's killing me
can you help me Dave
okay and then
aside from that so what if I could take
out a HELOC enough to pay for a home
cash
um because I have quite a bit of well
enough equity
um in my current home listen here's what
Tina you just you be you okay you go be
you that's what you need don't take out
a HELOC ever ever period ever sell your
stinking house and move and quit talking
to me about stress you're trading one
kind of stress for another because you
don't perceive the risk that after 30
years of doing what I do I've seen
people step in it up to their knees and
I'm begging you not to do that I'm
begging you all right Trevor's up
Trevor's in Fayetteville North Carolina
hi Trevor how are you
hey Mr Ramsey I'm doing well how are you
better than I deserve how can we help
so come on baby step one and there's
some maintenance some urgent some petty
that needs to be done on my wife and I's
car Petty did I go ahead yes small stuff
uh just small stuff like
a filter
uh cabin filter and
an engine air filter it's kind of small
stuff
yeah so that's that's my question
that goes in your budget okay and the
air filter is not Petty
it's one of those things that your
engines need to to run yeah but it's
it's a petty amount of money gotcha
there you go right exactly I don't know
the cabin air filters are a couple of
million dollars these days yeah I'm
thinking not but yeah I would um yeah
like the you gotta you have to you know
you're gonna change while you're doing
baby step one two and three and you're
living on a tight budget you're probably
going to change your oil and buy gas for
the car
and you're probably going to put a
filter in it so that's all just part of
your budget though it doesn't really
interrupt it other than it slows down
the amount of extra cash you have to
throw at debt anything you spend on
obviously can't go towards the debt but
you have to buy food you have to pay the
electricity I mean you have to keep the
car operating and so some basic stuff
like that's fine but yeah you know I
want to do a petty home remodel I want
to paint three rooms no
you wait on the room you wait on
painting your rooms until you get out of
debt or I want to Jack my car up or get
new shocks or something hang in there
yeah I want new Wheels no your Spinners
will wait or like James he put a special
thing muffler on his car so it's really
weird no he didn't okay
so it makes it a loud noise when he
drives down the road oh mine just came
that way from the fact
uh it says redneck we can hear you
coming man redneck on this window
sticker but there you go if somebody in
the parking lot says hey is Dave here
everyone just gets real quiet yeah there
it is right there yeah a new Raptor has
got a great voice it really does open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host today
John um
let's talk through for in the one minute
we got about going into the break the
what causes someone from a psychological
perspective to have a stressed out
situation like the lady a few minutes
ago on the double move things she didn't
want to move she wanted had a stress
stressful move and she's trading that
for another kind of stress and ignoring
the risk her body put a GPS pin in the
distress she had last time and said
let's never do this again and at any
cost at any cost and so it's the stress
she knows stresses she remembers the
devil I know and then there's this other
amorphous thing that probably won't
happen except you and I wouldn't have a
job if it didn't happen all the time and
so it's it's why people go gamble and
they gamble in the gamble in the gamble
they've been broke so they don't want to
be that but because they one time one
time it hit yep yeah that time God
Sharon put a quarter when we were like
20 something years old we were on this
little horrible Cruise Line put a
quarter in a slot machine and won like
130 bucks in quarters they were going
everywhere
if you put 600 in those machines before
we got off that boat I'm trying to do it
again that's exactly what it is isn't it
it's the same thing yeah yeah and you
know it's 25 or 28 years ago and I've
never let her forget it and it works in
the reverse with pain right so yeah just
don't do it man just don't do it this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
foreign
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions I'm the debt free
stage Todd and Rebecca are with us hey
guys how are you doing great how are you
better than we deserve where do you guys
live we live in the panhandle of
Nebraska known as Scotts Bluff all right
welcome to Nashville that's a bit of a
haul down here yeah 1200 miles one way
wow amazing well welcome how much debt
have you guys paid off paid off 62
000 in 13 months wow and your range of
income during that year we started off
at uh 101 000 and towards the end we
finished at 125. good for you what do
you guys do for a living
I'm an elementary teacher awesome what
grade do you teach fifth all right and
I'm a I'm all kinds of things but I am a
maintenance supervisor and a small uh
School District South of Scottsbluff ah
okay and started hitting on one of the
teachers huh exactly
the reason why we move we move out there
we're originally from Wyoming so yeah
yeah it was under him pitched dude sorry
all right what kind of debt was the 62
000. well we were pretty normal Dave uh
we had car loan student loan credit card
medical debt I mean we had just about
everything you could have absolutely how
long y'all been married
five years now years now okay
let's go looked at each other this much
fun this much fun the uh so after about
three years of marriage you look up and
say something's got to change how'd you
get on this Ramsay stuff oh boy
It's Kind of a Funny Story Dave I hope
you don't get offended by it uh very
seldom offended um you uh you came
across the radio station there in town
and uh
your commercial said you know getting
getting money on on credit is bad and
debit's good you know and I thought man
what is this Southern Man gonna tell
this Midwestern man how to spend his
money and sure is enough I was out there
working in the bus barn on Friday night
six o'clock trying to get work done and
uh
I started saying well you can get out
debt you can get out of debt and just
like uh Beetlejuice you just kind of
started appearing all over the place I
mean it was nuts the next day my dad
comes up to me and and he goes you know
what that Crazy Dave Ramsey man what you
do he wants you to make it he wants you
to take your bank account down to a
thousand dollars like oh man that is way
too crazy for me
two days later I looked it up found FPU
came home to my wife and I said hey you
know I'm gonna spend 100 bucks on or
whatever it is on this class to get us
out of debt and uh
long story short I ended up having a 10
hour round trip down to Kansas to pick
up some equipment for the school and I
listened to every single video of FPU
there and back and I came home that
night ready to go I was I was all in man
Rebecca he didn't take you on the ride
he did not
no I could see this coming a mile away
yep yeah we you're that guy aren't you
yeah
that's how it works
Avon and now he's got Dave Ramsey yes
exactly yeah yeah so what did you say
Rebecca you not your nutty husband I was
a little concerned about him yeah
I I just I had no idea about anything
that he was talking about and so when he
bought it and said let's watch this
together I said oh an activity to do
together that's wonderful
and I started watching it and to be very
honest with you Dave I was not into it
at first I was very scared to take that
risk because I always wanted a safety
blanket sure
but I stuck with it I trusted my husband
and the things that he was doing the
research he was doing and it definitely
paid off in the end
okay so you guys leaned into it together
but it was a little weird start there
yeah it was yeah okay that's fair that's
fair she had to pick between two nutty
guys and she went with that one yeah
well done thank you that's a good choice
good choice you know we how does it feel
to be free
oh it's fantastic it's life-changing I I
can't imagine anything better for our
family
um this is the life I wanted to live for
a long time I came from a family that
never believed in debt but had a hard
time getting out of debt you know and uh
now that we're here I'd never going back
again you guys live in a part of the
country that I mean it the whole farming
Cycles is is all dead so everybody you
live with and work with live in this
thing yeah we are surrounded by dead I
mean when you get a 300 000 tractor and
somebody that's making 35 000 a year
right I mean that's that's what we're
surrounded by the lean on your thousand
dollar Pro I mean Thousand Acre property
I mean that's a I mean your neighbors
can't breathe right oh yeah it's it's
kind of heartbreaking when you look at
all the poor guys around us that are
trying to supply us food and they're
just straddling with all these loans you
know they're struggling it's hard they
feed the world exactly but they're
they're amazing Farmers yeah yeah and
they work like crazy yeah yeah way to go
you two all right now that you did it
what are the keys out there to pay off
62 000 and 13 months what do you what do
you do to get out of debt
for me it's discipline
and perseverance you have to be
willing to do the hard things to get the
return in the end I had to be very
disciplined with my budget I had to oh I
have a little bit of money here I can
move it over here and go get my nails
done no big deal well as you can see my
nails are so me and Dave were just
talking about that before
our nails are looking rougher baloney
baloney it's been a while for him well
if you have it in your budget
absolutely I
it's not easy but it's it's worth it in
the end yeah the discipline the
perseverance and because of the
decisions we made you know if you live
like no one else later you can live and
give like no one else there's a price to
be paid to win exactly yeah well we do
we had a couple prices to pay I mean
three weeks after I took FPU I went home
and sold my GTO my race car four months
later I came home again I told my wife
look if we want this to go faster we're
going to have to get rid of the SRT8
Jeep for an Impala yeah that was a hard
blow to the ego and you knew he was
serious huh I did what did the GTO sell
for uh we ended up selling it for about
39 000. goodness gracious yeah it was
one of only 700 in the world so it was
really hard to get rid of but
um you chose your family's future that's
right yeah I I figured you know what
when I'm out of debt I can go get
whatever car I want drive whatever I
want and do whatever I want so yeah so
let me just help you people out there in
America if a guy sells his 39 000 GTO
for the good of his family's future he's
what's known as a man not a boy that's
very manly pretty impressive thank you
pretty impressive dude I'm so proud of
you so cool to meet you guys you're
amazing you too thank you very very well
done you brought the kid you brought the
kiddo with you uh and let's bring the
child up age and name and all that stuff
give us an introduction here yeah this
is uh Malia May she's two years old all
right Malia may very good hey we've got
the live and give bundle for you which
is the number one best seller the baby
steps millionaires book on your next up
or you'll be a millionaire and then of
course Total Money Makeover book which
you guys are plugged into in the
Financial Peace University you plugged
into so you can give some of these
things you can live with some of these
things they're gifts for you to say
thanks for coming down here very very
cool very well done I'm so proud of
y'all thank you good work thanks you are
heroes and people that make decisions
like that selling that car that's that
was not an easy call man that was pretty
serious right there that's that's
impressive very impressive all right
Todd Rebecca and Malia from Scott's
Bluff Nebraska 62 000 paid off in 13
months making 101 to 125. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream you ready
Malia three two one we're dead free
oh
wow all right
that's amazing the first time I ever saw
that was many decades ago I was sitting
in a small group in Financial Peace
University I was leading the group
and this old boy from Kentucky came in
and he was a big old guy like that guy
his wife was a tiny little thing
tears started running down her face and
she said I've never felt as loved by my
husband in our 10 years of marriage as I
do right now and I said what he sold
this unbelievable knife collection he
had for ten thousand dollars to get his
family out of debt and it was one of his
most prized possessions and he put his
family ahead of that of stuff and boy
she felt loved wow it was pretty
impressive this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're a new listener
and we know there's a bunch of you based
on our ratings and rankings out there
you don't know what we're talking about
half the time around here if you want to
learn about the inside talk like baby
steps and debt snowballs and all that
kind of stuff
hit ramseysolutions.com click on the get
started button it's a free process we'll
help you identify where you are and what
your next best steps are and you can
join in this whole conversation get
started free service at
ramsaysolutions.com Ray is in Boston hi
Ray welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey
Dave thank you so much for having me on
how's it going today better than we
deserve sir how can we help
yeah so I'm wondering um yeah so I've
been listening to you for uh for a few
months now I was just wondering if it
was a smart idea to uh to dip into my
savings to pay off all the debt I want
just you know rip the Band-Aid right off
generally yes why would you not do that
just because uh you know um in in
Industry I'm in right now is going
through a lot of layoffs so I'm just
wary of just like you know should I
um just get rid of all my you know get
rid of a big portion of my savings what
if I get laid off in my two months or
something
what industry are you in
uh Tech
what do you do
I'm a data software data engineer you
can get a job in 20 seconds
yeah yeah but if big Tech lays you off
that's what's known as a blessing
and there's people hiring I mean I got I
could hire 10 data Engineers this moment
I got I got we got job postings right
now and I'm not the only one there's a
short man you you you're sitting in the
cat bird seat you can get a job in 30
seconds if you're any good are you good
yeah
you're fine
you're fine I mean
your particular job is going to be
alleviated in the next six weeks
no no then quit whining and worrying
about what might happen and go live your
life
yeah so my question is I I'm so I
actually have a um yeah so I make about
a 135 a year but and I have a 20 bonus
coming up should I just take that bonus
and just yeah you also have you also
have money and savings
yep I have about 85 000 saved up okay
and so how much is your bonus
uh bonuses about
um after taxes I'm not sure that's about
25 of my about 20 of my entire salary
okay so about another 25 Grand or 30
grand yeah on top of 85.
am I getting this right so you got like
125 000 cash laying around how much debt
have you got
I got I got about 23 000. oh
it's a shame about Ray
pay it off poor Ray's only got a hundred
thousand left over after he paid off his
debt how's he gonna make it I don't know
how he's gonna make it he's gonna starve
Raymond pay off your debts today Ray
do you hear what you just said
yeah I'm just very sort of like I like I
I like lovely afternoon okay listen
you're using your emotions to make
financial decisions
yeah because your math it sucks
you have 125 000 and 25 000 in debt and
so after you pay off all your debt and
you're 100 debt free this is not even a
question you should have to ask yeah so
you're living up in the worry Zone Dale
Carnegie one of the great minds of a
another Century said that 80 of what we
worry about never occurs and their
percentage of the 20 that we worry about
we don't have any control over anyway so
quit spending all your energy and
burning calories worrying you spend a
lot of time fretting it's good to get a
piece of paper and just do the facts of
your friends exercise if you pay this
debt off you have no bills you have 80
percent of an annual income so you got
what 10 months of of pay and cash you're
fine too much you're good and gosh wow
yes Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff is in Atlanta hi
Jeff welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey good afternoon Dave good afternoon
John
um my question is a little bit different
than the prior
prior caller I'm looking to make sure
I'm not being so detached and only
looking at the numbers
I see what you're saying Jeff okay no
that's okay you can do it you can do
either one we'll just we'll just we'll
just tell you the truth either way so
what's up how can we help that that's
what I'm good with so a couple of years
ago I went through a divorce and I've
got three kids caught in the middle uh I
wound up getting remarried last year but
my ex-wife moved
about an hour away
so we went back to the court system the
court system also ultimately just
decided that even though I retain the
marital home so that the kids could stay
in their schools that there's no reason
why she's not allowed to leave
um so there for a while we were doing 50
50 and I'm taking about an hour and a
half to get the kids to school in the
morning and then another hour to get
home ultimately this is not sustainable
it's not good for the kids to be in the
car that long not good for anybody yeah
my financial question is do I sell my
home that I have at a three percent rate
and buy something on that side of town
so I can see my kids more even though
it's going to increase my monthly
expenses after the court cases Mike
where's your where's your work
I work from home oh okay what about your
new spouse are you married remarried
I am I am remarried she would then have
you know she she works 10 minutes down
the road now so if we move she'll be
commuting an hour to work
but so it's kind of
I don't I don't know what to do because
basically if I sold this house about
halfway in between yeah halfway in
between
here's the deal ask yourself this
question what's the percentage rate your
kids are worth
it doesn't even matter financially right
mathematically it's not that big a deal
but what you because what here's the
thing you're not going to prosper
financially merely or as a dad
in a situation that's not sustainable
and so when you get yourself in a place
that's sustainable you'll make more
money you'll have a better quality life
and so Landing 30 Dropout GPS pin 30
minutes between each two of these things
so 30 minutes to the kid 30 minutes for
your new wife to work and we got a
pretty decent life now that's not that
unusual commute crap in Atlanta that's a
short commute that's my commute to the
office every day and I'll tell you this
she would have to be a very special
human being
to be 10 minutes from our house have
this new life and then suddenly have to
commute an hour for what will this the
quiet voice in Her Mind will be for
somebody else's kids that's going to be
tough long term so keep that what Dave
said it's really important the
sustainability sustainability yeah the
relational sustainability the physical
sustainability that commute is just
overwhelming so yeah I'm probably moving
closer to them I don't know exactly what
that looks like in your situation but
removing that direction uh to where we
can do this and here's the thing too
um
I don't know how I didn't ask how old
these kids are but I'll bet you in 10
years most of this problem's gone right
and that's when when parents get
divorced and they are asking questions
about their kids I always tell them you
just switched from an annual game to a
decade game you're playing a long
connection you want your kids to be able
to look back and say
that guy my dad never stopped pursuing
me my mom never I don't care what the
court said I don't care we have a crazy
parent I've got a box full of letters
under my bed that my dad wrote me every
single week my dad always he sold his
house and moved out you're playing long
games playing long game yeah it's all
along games it's a 10-year 10-year and
also I mean you know like stuff like
child support and stuff like you know
your need to be physically present in
their life on a
when they're 18 you don't even have that
option because they leave they're gone
so uh most of the time or they should
there's that so you know that's um yeah
you know you've got to do that and
you're not being cold and detached
you're just trying to be wise this is
there's so many things pulling at you
Jeff I mean you've got a new wife that
you want to honor and serve you've got
this um an ex-wife that bailed on the on
the agreement y'all made yeah and the
court that went along with it and you
gotta you need to try to do your job and
eat she's the new wife's got to do her
job I mean there's so many things
pulling at you here and you're not a
single part of your question was selfish
nope yeah it was all Duty and service
which means you're a great guy yeah so
you're you're right on track and you're
not being cold or calculated
it's not an interest rate thing do make
the move it'll be worth it
you'll probably make it up in gas
savings this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show but we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
author of the book own your past and
change your future on number one best
seller and we're here to answer your
questions about your life and your money
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five well John the
the crypto um
gossip meal Mill continues oh thank
goodness man apparently now um it's not
much real attorney has gathered up
clients who are seeking five billion
dollars in Damages from FTX celebrity
endorsers
in other words a celebrity went on and
told you to buy crypto from FTX which
went bankrupt went belly up because uh
the guy was running a Ponzi scheme
basically like we didn't know that about
crypto but anyway Tom Brady his ex-wife
Giselle actor Larry David Shark Tank
star Kevin O'Leary and NBA legend
Shaquille O'Neal five billion dollars
well I guess uh Matt Damon's
um thing of fortune favors the bold that
was a difference that was a different
company yeah that one didn't get he's
not yeah I don't understand the suit I'd
probably have to learn more about what
Moskowitz is trying to do I didn't know
you could sue and endorse her you can
sue anybody for anything in hopes you
can hassle them into giving you money
even if you're going to lose the lawsuit
right because these companies don't
these people don't want to spend five
years in court with this ambulance Trace
chasing and go through all their
and go through all their everything that
they've ever every underwear drawer
they've ever unpacked in their socks
they don't want to go through all of
that even though the guy hasn't got a
chance of winning because endorsing
something when you're a celebrity that
you know nothing about has been done
since time began they're not liable for
the FTX crash so but hey that's absolute
hogwash I mean I I'm not a fan of FTX
I'm not a fan of crypto certainly not a
fan of bankman fried or fried whichever
way you want to say it and uh pride is
my preference and yeah but the uh in so
many ways yeah uh but you know hey the
whole thing is a scam but come on dude
here's what's important Tom Brady might
be stupid for endorsing it but he's not
liable he's not a criminal yeah that's
just dumb I think the the important part
of the story The most important thing
that all of us need to put into our
pocket and not forget
is that when it came down to it only one
celebrity
said no I
and it's James favorite celebrity of all
time Taylor Swift Taylor Swift asked FDX
about its legality of what they were
selling they offered her 100 million
dollars she walked away from it and she
walked away yeah she thought it was a
scam
you gotta love it I can just see her
like writing a song in her bedroom like
she's writing her diary and then she
picks up the phone and she just says hey
can you tell me that these are not
unregistered Securities and the FTX guys
were like we'll call you back and then
she went back to singing herself this is
according to the attorney who's doing
the lawsuit
so I'm not saying Taylor didn't I didn't
didn't turn down the endorsement because
it was scummy I cannot hear her saying
can you tell me these are not
unregistered securities
I'm calling absolute Bull on that that
is not a phrase that would come out of
Taylor Swift's mouth okay I don't think
you're a true Swifty Dave
I'm not a hater I like Taylor I mean I
I'm not it's not a music thing but I
mean I don't she's a Nashville
originally came up here we all watched
her grow her career I'm not a hater but
I mean you know can you tell me this is
an illegal maybe would she say that
maybe unless somebody put this phrase in
her mouth and said you need to ask them
this sure but this guys this guy's full
of it
she did not say that she did turn them
down though to her credit yeah we'll
give her big time stars for that 100
million bucks sponsorship for the tour
uh well before negotiations broke down
last spring sources told the financial
times with the FTX then billionaire CEO
bankman fried uh intimately involved in
the talk so he's sitting with time he's
trying to get it he's trying to get
Taylor to sign up here for a hundred
million dollars of course he was going
to pay her in crypto that's probably why
I'm kidding maybe not but anyway yeah ah
hey kudos to Taylor James I think you
should be proud of your favorite singer
songwriter yeah like she did good when
the chips were down she did good yeah
well I um
hey honestly because
the the other guys I kind of I can't
even accuse them of being sellouts no
like I don't I don't know that they just
gave a you know that they just took
money I think they actually believed in
the crypto stupid stuff and actually
thought it was a good idea to invest in
the crypto stupid stuff and so they said
yeah I mean like I don't think Shaq is a
is a shill for any you can buy for any
amount of money to sell anything I
really don't believe that about no and
and you and I both people come pitch us
and say hey you wanna you wanna
advertise this product and I had a
meeting today with somebody walking me
through here's what this looks like and
here's what we're about and here's what
we do and we just say no yeah if we
don't like it or if we like it but if I
say yes if I wouldn't sell it if I
wouldn't try to talk my own relative my
best friend into doing it then I'm not
going to tell you guys to do it that's
right that's our rule at Ramsay we don't
endorse stuff but these guys honestly
they they probably bought some of them
they probably told their friends get in
on this yeah yeah that's all right yeah
it's a strange lawsuit but it's a it's a
bogus lawsuit once again Taylor Swift
I'm Just on top of the heat Moskowitz
Adam Moskowitz
and he's out in the news
he's doing interviews
he's that kind of attorney
the kind of attorney instead of having a
case he tries to try it in the court of
public opinion yeah yeah this is what's
known as a glorified ambulance Chaser
right here there you know so companies
basically if y'all don't know most
companies just cave you sue them they
just go oh God I don't want to be tied
up in court and people do too and you
know who didn't do that the other day
Paltrow
she took the fake ski accident guy
all the way to ground baby you know what
he got embarrassed that's what he got
embarrassed and now now they're going
after him for her attorney's Feast of
course absolutely I hope they get them
absolutely yeah because you know because
he thought he could just bully a
celebrity and instead of going through
the hassle that the that you bully the
celebrity they'll give you money even
though you know you're wrong and hit
that guy you know he he knows I didn't
know much about it I was just surprised
that she showed up at the in court this
is what when when people out there uh in
the think tank things and all that say
we need tort reform that's what they
mean is these bogus butt attorneys suing
people that are in the spotlight and
knowing that the even though the lawsuit
holds absolutely no water at all zero
basis to win they think they can just do
it enough that uh that you're just gonna
write a check and occasionally run into
one that won't and that uh took them all
the way to ground good for her good for
her so that's how it's done so yeah
that's I'm sorry I
we endure stuff for a living we are not
if the company that we endorse
unbeknownst to us does something wrong
we are not financially or legally liable
we believe in it we don't endorse it we
check it out we don't endorse it if we
don't we we do our best we're not good
we're not we're not shills and I don't
think these guys are seals and I think
this guy just he thinks he's going to
hassle these celebs into giving him
money five billion dollars I'm a
I'm attorney
no you're not you're a freaking
ambulance Chaser I'll just say Taylor
Swift was right again yeah there it is
who knew who knew there it is James knew
she's a futurist a prophetess this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Virginia Is With Us Virginia is in
Charlotte North Carolina hi Virginia
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
feelings about a situation with his
family and I'm struggling with feeling
guilty about feeling resentful and then
I'm you know kind of like saying things
that are just not nice and it's it's
putting a strain on a relationship and
it makes me just wanna
give up but I don't want to give up
because I love them so much and
that's why I'm calling so what's what's
the situation
his parents moved in with him a few
years ago to help after a devastating
divorce
and now you know we've been dating for
like over a year and and things are good
but you know
kind of like they're going to be
permanently there and he feels obligated
to continue supporting them because you
know they kind of sold everything to go
help them and I just don't know if we
were talking about marriage and starting
life together and I don't know if he'll
ever really be able to let go of that
and be focused on a household we would
create together you know because he
would maybe let's say if he moved out
and maybe charged them rent or something
but it wouldn't cover you know any of
the expenses so most so about let's
let's talk let's stop talking about him
what kind of Life do you want
do you let me let me tell you this
before you answer it it's okay to say I
want to be married
to somebody and nobody else lives in our
house for a while
I want to fill in the blank which by the
way would be pretty normal yeah
um I I
what do you want
because that's what we both we both have
kids you know that we'd be bringing into
it and that's hard enough without
everything else and and I really we each
don't by ourselves make a lot of money
and it's not about the money but it's
just if we were to combine forces we
could really get ahead and change our
family tree and and it's just so you
know what you want exactly
say even if he lets them say living
there at his house but it would still be
kind of like
he'd probably still have to support a
lot you know because they can't really
afford to pay off did you get hurt in
your first marriage
yes
you're not done there
and what you're trying to do is you're
trying to get back out there quote
unquote you found somebody you like this
guy you started making plans and
thinking about tomorrow which you
haven't done in a while
and your body is saying hey we've done
this before and it almost got us killed
and the way you're trying to solve that
angst and that fear is by controlling
every future variable down the road
and what I want to tell you is you can't
do that you're going to make yourself
nuts
because you could marry somebody and two
months in it's you all have this nice
small little house and you're and you
are changing your family tree and then
his dad passes away and mom has to go
like life just happens
or he gets hit by a butt like this is
life the difference between you dating
right now is you know up front what
you're what you're walking into
and so you're gonna have to
as scary as it is put yourself out there
to get hurt again that's the only way
relationships work you got to go all in
or say
here's what I want here's what I need if
you can't do that if you're not
interested in that that's gonna hurt
like bloody hell and
that's what grief is and then we're
gonna pick up pick it up and we're gonna
go figure out something else
you're trying to do it all you can't I
can hear it how you talk it's all just
chaos in there right so with him
comes a package
you can't control
the package he's got kids he's got
parents in his house
you can't control that
and he's got values that say I do this
and I do this and I do this and I'm
going to do this
it's in there too it's kind of obvious
where this is going to go
so you're you're either going to sign up
for that
and be happy about it or you're going to
say you know that's not the picture I've
got I don't want to do that
now I want to be fair to him have you
sat down and been very clear
I am not interested in moving forward in
this relationship
If this relationship is going to include
x y and z
um I think that like the details maybe
haven't been ironed out where we got
that far yet to talk about what it would
actually look like if we were to try to
start a home together
um
I think he kind of more says don't worry
about it it'll all work out and I'm
wanting more it won't no it won't nope
because his didn't work out
so uh
I'm confused they moved in with him to
help him after the divorce but now
they're the ones that need help
that's yeah that's kind of like my issue
is I feel like well they didn't you know
they were fine before and I know they
missed out on all that you know house
boom and everything whereas if they kept
their house they could have had a lot of
equity and then they missed out on all
that so now they really don't have
anything so they did really give up
everything to you know and they're
probably so so the house that he's in he
owns and they're living with him yeah
can he just give him that house
I I think that would be beautiful and
essentially he probably in in effect
would be but no I don't I wouldn't do it
in fact I would just say you're on your
own you stand on your own two feet
you're like grown people now and here's
your house here's a house I'm marrying
her I'm moving into her place
and y'all y'all y'all got to figure it
out because you're going to pay the
bills over here
no I mean that sounds like do they have
jobs
no they how old are these people
okay and they have no money
they didn't move in with him to help him
they moved in with him because they were
broke
I don't know about that well I'm telling
you I mean they didn't go from Rich to
broke while living in a free house
I think yeah maybe they weren't before
but then they were able to retire when
they moved in kind of thing
and that's good I'm glad they can do
that it's just that now I do struggle
thinking wait like you said wait they
didn't help before but now they're
dependent on you you know here's the big
picture you were spending a lot of time
in his head and in their head get out
get out of their heads
the rent's too expensive yeah you've got
to sit down and say here's what I want
here's what I need
and is that is that a picture you can go
with if you can't then um this hurts but
oh we can't do this and it's going to be
it's going to be treadful and
heartbreaking if you get hurt again but
better now than than getting into this
because you're gonna spend your whole
life but you're pissed off right you're
really angry
I know I know but you're looking at this
and you're going this is cray-cray and I
can see cray-cray a mile away and I
don't want to do it and it's making you
angry I don't really I'm not saying I
blame you but no I don't blame you at
all you're working awfully hard to make
anger sound sweet but and also you know
this situation makes you angry and you
keep going back into it yeah so you're
gonna sit down with him and go look if
this I've got to have some boundaries
here with you and with your parents for
me to be able to function in this
otherwise it doesn't feel right to me
I'm not going to be able to go forward
yeah and you gotta you gotta heal from
your old divorce yeah big time and if
you haven't sat down and and
with a good counselor yeah with a good
counselor for sure but you haven't sat
down and written your old self a letter
says
to your to you
I got hurt real bad and just lay that
stuff out there because your body's
still trying to solve for it lay it out
there
and say here's what I want moving
forward and then if this guy isn't that
guy then that so be it there's gonna be
somebody else out there
it's a mess
so thanks for calling Virginia what's
the probability John that um
is that it's uh her woundedness
that he's probably that he could be
thinking real clearly that he's going to
be have good boundaries with his parents
and by her woundedness has just got her
freaked out about it the possibility I
think if she is she's so terrified that
if I say exactly what I need if I put my
boundaries down he might go yeah and
she's experienced that loss before so
she's willing to give up her Integrity
who she wants to be she doesn't want to
be an angry person she said I want to be
a sweet person yeah she's giving all
that up
because she doesn't want to get left
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
watch and guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage
Christopher and Kelly are with us hey
guys how are you hi great how are you
better than we deserve welcome where do
you live uh just north of Orlando
Florida in Leesburg yeah fun welcome to
Nashville and how much debt have you
guys paid off
459 thousand dollars how long did this
take six and a half long years I love it
and your range of income during that six
and a half long years about a hundred
thousand when we started and we're just
over 200 000 now phenomenal what do you
all do for a living
I own my own business doing what animal
transport mostly dogs oh cool
oh and I'm a senior risk manager for
manager for a large Entertainment
Company ah very good good for you oh I'm
in Orlando imagine that okay yeah yeah
welcome to Nashville good good good good
so 459 000 six and a half years that's
your mortgage yes
way to go you two what's this house
worth uh 493 thousand dollars very good
how much is in your retirement accounts
300 000. all right almost millionaires
close just this close Okay so what
started you guys on this Ramsay stuff
six and a half years ago uh well it's
our second marriage for both of us but
uh when we started our marriage together
we were still separate uh so if she had
her money I had mine
um uh their bills were paid separately I
did the mortgage she did the utilities
and we were
for the most part uh in love but it got
to the point where in my previous
marriage there was still a contest over
who would pay my ex's lawyer fees and
the court decided it was my
responsibility to pay for those fees and
I said don't agree with that so they set
a hearing I blew off the hearing and two
weeks later I was in jail for contempt
well so that was my I had it moment uh
sitting in jail alone going how did it
go from being a naval officer and a
pilot to this guy I don't like this guy
and I was about to lose her because she
had no idea that was going on I didn't
tell her oh
or gave it to him and said I think he
think he with his finances so here's
when you're in jail you got time on your
hands right
seven luxurious days in jail
oh nothing nothing is better than that
call Kelly home to your mom like hey you
know that guy I've been telling you
about he's in jail yeah she was actually
visiting at the time of course she was
of course she was way to go Christopher
you go big man
not the favorite son-in-law so uh man
okay so that says hey I can't I can't
keep things from her financially and B
uh well you need to get on the same page
and see we got to straighten this whole
mess up yes absolutely and we started in
April of 2016 with your DVD FPU at a
church and I was Furious because like I
gotta work all day and now I got to
drive to a church at six o'clock at
night and watch a show about money and
I'm already embarrassed you know I was
already scared and I didn't like you
when I first met you on your class
because you kept pointing out how stupid
I was and I wasn't feeling it was really
pretty it was really personal yeah every
now and then Kelly will be like
go home with your ribs bruised from her
elbow yeah yeah but I think it was the
sixth lesson when you said you if you do
this you might be that person that could
pay somebody's light bill without them
knowing it yeah and when I heard that I
thought wow you know I want to be that
guy I don't like being the broke guy I
want to be that guy so that's your whole
life has been a life of service right
you yeah that's who you are yeah but uh
I wasn't paying attention nothing I did
was intentional it was just reactionary
and I thought I could out earn I always
made enough money I can do this I can
win by making more money and that's not
true yeah you can't you got to get rid
of the stuff that's in your way and now
I know what peace really feels like and
so you knock out the other dads you get
you get the attorney's fees gone
obviously you uh or you wouldn't be here
and and uh you get on the same page and
six and a half years later your house
was paid for and you're almost
millionaires correct yes we actually
hired a lawyer neither one of us liked
but he did have the heart of a teacher
and he was like you need to listen to me
right now because signing lifetime
alimony what the heck were you thinking
so he kind of got another thud from him
because he was former Navy Jag so he was
I was a lieutenant in the Navy he was a
captain and he was just I was like yes
sir yes sir yes sir yes sir right how
did you do this to yourself I'm like I
don't know sir I just don't know but uh
but following your plan uh really did it
it really works it's it's a miserable
baby step too when you owe that much
money yeah baby step six felt like baby
step two to me yeah I really hated that
mortgage but when I got the email that
said we're sad to see you go I was like
I'm not bye
peace out no Kelly great but
yeah I mean this had to be scary it was
it really like you smile real big but
like you hung in there oh yeah what kept
you in there this is scary yeah it
honestly like looking at looking back on
it now and the fact that there was this
other person in his life they had three
children they were in their 20s but I'm
looking at it going okay well I my
marriage didn't work out and now I'm
with this guy and you know the love of
my life and I'm super excited about our
relationship starting out a couple years
in this happens and I'm like oh my gosh
of course my parents are like run yeah
you know you don't need this you gotta
go you know too much better I mean but I
honestly when we you know I I honestly
prayed about it and I was like you know
God if this is my my guy my man I'm
standing by him no matter what and we
got through this and I'm like we can get
through absolutely anything hey man I
mean it's just it's been great well it's
awesome yeah very well done okay now
when people ask and they say gosh you
paid off your house
you're almost baby steps millionaires
you did it all in six and a half years
and not to mention all the attorney
stuff's off your back all that stuff
yeah
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is really to follow
the steps I mean they're one through
seven for a reason go start at the first
one and work your way through and it
does get tough but like you said you can
you can stop after baby step three and
kind of pump the brakes a little bit
take a bit of a break take a little
vacation support the win of getting
through those first three steps and then
just you know move on I mean we were we
were in baby step three we were getting
ready to go on the cruise with you and
we you know pandemic hit but we had the
emergency fund we had everything in
place and it was really really a great
blessing yeah I have the mother of all
budgets on my computer so we get paid
weekly and so I have a 52-week budget
and when the pandemic hit I just zeroed
out both of our incomes and I went ah
we're good we'll be all right wow all we
have all we had was the house payment
and a light bill and a cell phone bill
like yeah we're gonna be fine so for us
it wasn't an event it was like you said
an inconvenience but we were we were
happy yeah and for everybody listening
whose spouse is really excited about the
monthly budget meeting
Christopher makes poor Kelly have a
weekly budget meeting so count your
blessings in case you didn't figure it
out she's the free spirit and when I
turned the computer around she just said
I can't no no I can't I just can't I
can't go next month hit me up next month
or next week well done you too proud of
you how's it feel to be a hundred
percent free no payments of any kind it
changes how I see things I I didn't know
what to expect I thought it was going to
be this weird euphoric something when I
paid off the house when we paid off the
house together we would just start
floating or something but nothing
happened and I thought well that's weird
but Kelly pointed out what we planned to
do it so it's not a surprise we said we
we actually were projected not to pay
off our house until June of 2024 and we
just pushed it harder and pushed it
harder and I wanted to shout out to our
FP or our financial advisor uh who's one
of your recommended uh Jeff ackler
because he was my accountability person
on the house so he I wish I didn't ask
him to do that I said someone needs to
call me on this house payment thing
because I'm going to want to do
something else with the money and
because I'm the spender and he said okay
so he started calling me every month
how's it going whoa I like this guy
right hey good job you two very well
done hey we've got the live and give
bundle for you the baby steps
millionaires book The Total Money
Makeover book and the financial peace
membership
Christopher and Kelly from Orlando
Florida 459
000 paid off in six and a half years
from 100 to 200 000 income house
scream three three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
free oh different get out of jail free
card this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
guys if you want to help us out here on
the show we would appreciate it there's
a couple things you can do one is you
can click the follow or subscribe button
if you're on a podcaster on YouTube
click the share button or share a link
or tell people where you're listening if
you're listening on talk radio or
watching on YouTube or TBN tell people
to join us there we would appreciate
that also leave a five star review one
Stars don't help Mama said if you hadn't
got anything nice to say don't say
anything at all just move on
we'd love to have you do that so share
it follow it the show that is and I'll
leave us a five-star review hey let's do
a little mental exercise look ahead out
there with me 90 days
it's July
you got a thousand bucks in the bank
two of your credit cards are paid off
that aren't right now no payments
you check out at the grocery store you
don't have a panic attack
how would all of that feel
uh like the starting steps of financial
peace two words that don't go together
like Airline service
yeah some of you have never had that
feeling in your entire life but you can
for the first time ever maybe or maybe
for a new time get control of your money
starts with Financial Peace University
it's our nine week course it's helped
over 10 million people beat debt build
wealth and become outrageously generous
the average graduate pays off fifty
three hundred dollars in debt and saves
twenty seven hundred dollars in 90 days
that's an eight thousand dollar change
in 90 days
that's a good deal
Financial Peace University check it out
ramseysolutions.com
FPU Adams in Chicago hey Adam welcome to
the Ramsey Show
good afternoon thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so my mom is facing a foreclosure and is
asking me to lend her fifty thousand
dollars to stop this and we do not have
much time I'm looking for uh to get some
a different perspective on how to
proceed with this and what I should do
wow
fifty thousand dollars she's behind on
her payments
yes
he gives so much as how much is her
monthly payment
uh for monthly payment I believe is
about a thousand dollars now she's not
paying a payment in four years
she has a mortgage didn't exactly sneak
up on her did it
no it did not it did not why is she not
paid a payment in four years I thought
this was going to work
she's been making a monthly payment on a
HELOC uh with a balloon payment it
reached its maturity date and then it
was all due at once I did not have the
funds so this is she's not behind on her
payment she has a balloon on her e-lock
yes oh okay that's not nearly as
irresponsible but close okay wow all
right so what's the house worth
house is worth around three hundred
thousand dollars and what is the first
mortgage amount
uh I do not have that much information I
believe it's around two hundred thousand
with this other HELOC at around 90 to
100 000.
I thought you said it was 50 000 to pay
it off
she's asking me to lend her fifty
thousand she will up put up uh forty
thousand oh she has a ninety thousand
dollar HELOC
yes that's that's called on a balloon
yes and her first mortgage you think the
200 includes that so you think our first
mortgage 110
that'd be about right
I I believe that's the scenario she
hasn't shared all of the information or
been transparent yeah well transparency
kind of comes with that request for 50
Grand
I agree so um
so uh can you give her 50 Grand do you
have fifty thousand dollars
yes that's all that I have okay so
that's why it's 50 yeah
um how old is your mom
uh 39.
how old are you
she had you when she was 14.
no you said 39 and 25. 40 44 my
apologies she's 44.
yes oh okay all right I'm just trying to
catch up here because that my mouth my
mouth brain went nuts there for a second
how did you get 50 000 bucks at 25.
that's impressive
saving it
okay um
do you have any idea how long this has
all been going on with your mom
yes I believe last year is when she
began to become aware of the situation
uh she has put it off and not made
progress have they started the
foreclosure proceeding
she went into forbearance and that's
where we are now we are ending before we
aren't she is
correct correct you aren't in this
correct she's in forbearance and
forbearance just simply means she's
paying payments uh so that they don't
foreclose so they've not started
foreclosure what state is she in
Illinois
and why is she unable to get another
home equity loan to pay this one off
with a different bank
no why
she has no income currently
okay why isn't she working
that is a great question that I have
also asked
because here's what we're getting at you
hand her fifty thousand dollars she pays
this thing down
and in 12 months we're right in the
exact same spot we're not going to have
a 90 000 balloon but she doesn't have a
job she doesn't have any way to keep
paying the mortgage already has
like there's there's a pattern here
that's not sustainable for her and her
life
and uh the question is are we just
giving a drink a drink or are we really
helping someone get sober for the last
time and that's the question you always
want to ask yourself and um
I think you're giving a drunk a drink I
don't hear anything in this pattern
right now that indicates she's going to
do anything there's nothing in this
pattern that is responsible
so if I were advising your mom and she
came to me and told me her story
um I would tell her to sell her house
before it gets foreclosed on
it needs to go on the market this week
with a good real estate agent
you can find one at elp's endorsed local
providers people we endorse in your
neighborhood that are high octane high
protein at ramsaysolutions.com you need
to sell this she needs to sell this
house
she can't afford it she doesn't work
she is she does not want to sell this
house it's a two unit apartment and she
wants to live in one and take it I don't
really care what she wants she's asking
her child for fifty thousand dollars
and no you can't give her fifty thousand
dollars
absolutely that is true I will advise
her to that um ultimately I've tried to
talk with her and she seems that the old
she's going to take it all the way to
the last uh day of this and that's right
and there's nothing you can do about
that we all have people that we love
that do stupid things
and it hurts you to watch them do things
that are hurtful to themselves you
cannot control her actions
and it is not your fault if she chooses
to do that she has options she has had
options like get a job she's had options
like refinance this before her credit
got bad while she had a job and get rid
of this balloon she had options like not
taking out the home equity loan in the
first place she has options now like
selling the house all of these are much
better options than going to your own
son who's 25 years old and asking him
for fifty thousand dollars
right
so let me ask you this okay you're not
married are you
no okay
um
can you I don't know if you can get your
head around this but if you were married
and you had
a little boy
and 25 years later can you imagine
asking your own little boy for fifty
thousand dollars because you can't seem
to get your crap together
I can't even imagine doing that I can't
imagine doing that I might ask deloney
for money but I'm not saying one of my
kids for money
I just couldn't do it I could I couldn't
I mean I just there's something there's
something broken here man my son went to
buy something the other day at Sonic and
he said
I I just I'll pay and I couldn't allow
it like I it's not his job it's my job
to feed you you're my son yeah and it's
not your job honey you're 25 years old
you busted you're not your job and you
busted your butt to have this money and
it doesn't even fix the problem if you
had 20 million dollars extra laying
around and you wanted to give her fifty
thousand dollars you wanna give her
ninety thousand dollars I'd say well we
can talk about how to do that but this
is all you've got and there's just so
much ethically and morally wrong with
this whole conversation
please don't do it please ask her to
sell her house that's what's good for
her too by the way this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney number one best-selling author
and host of the Dr John deloney show
mental health expert relationship expert
is my co-host today the phone number
here is triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Michael is in
San Antonio hey Michael welcome to the
Ramsay show
hold on hey what's up Texas good to have
you brother
a couple of things I finished FPU last
week
um everything's paid off except my house
now good
me and my wife have been working
diligently for that good so we're
looking at moving out of the city we
found about a little less than 100 acres
we want to buy it's a pretty good price
but we're hearing a lot of different
things when we talked to a conventional
lender
they're saying that we should you know
go ahead and do our construction loan
and everything which bumps the whole
loan up about 450
uh when we talk to just the land loan
there's like no just do the land loan
but you know know that your down payment
is going to be 20 maybe 15
well and talking with a friend we were
looking at we're looking at all options
so we looked at a manufactured home
option and it's a manufactured home
option which I'm kind of shocked but
these homes look as nice as they do but
there's they have a program where they
will go into the landowner make a cash
offer which is significantly reduced and
we'll just say 500 000 at this point
and uh and then they sell us the land
for that cost with the manufactured home
all these people are telling me
different things
I'm gonna have bad points
it's hard to sift through
all of this okay thoughts
always have thoughts I'm an expert on my
opinion
um
how old are you
I am 61. okay and um what's your
household income
about 121 000. do you have any money
I'm sorry do you have any money
how much money do you have
and it's liquid that we could use toward
the down payment and stuff that wasn't
what I asked how much money is in your
retirement account
couple hundred I guess I'm retired from
the Army I'm a disabled vet thanks for
your service okay all right so you're
married and your wife that your total
household nest egg is 200 Grand plus 75
liquid
correct you own a home now
yes okay so if I understand you're right
you've bought uh or you're trying to buy
100 acres then you're going to build a
house on
correct okay manufactured housings we
don't do that's a fancy word for trailer
okay and the 100 of them go down in
value
even the nice ones
we want to buy something that goes up in
value
which would be a house
that makes sense
it does so your current house is worth
what
uh five hundred and three thousand and
what do you owe on it
170 I mean okay so you got 200 there and
you got 75 liquid and this property is
400.
now the property is 650. 650 000.
and you're going to put a house on it
so you're gonna have a million dollars
in this project and you make 120 and
you're 61.
correct
pretty steep
you know we we run the numbers we don't
have any other expenses that's the thing
yeah I mean we owe nothing anywhere no
um except you're about to except you're
about to be well 650 700 000 in debt
When the Smoke Clears on this
I mean what you're saying okay what
price what price house are you putting
on that what price house you're gonna
put on this 650 000 price property
to downscale quite a bit to about a 2
000 square foot house what are you going
to spend on it to build it
thinking around three yeah and 650 is
like 950 so it's a million dollars minus
275 that you got to put down on it and
so you've got a you know what a 700 000
mortgage roughly correct is that where
we end up okay I if you're my dad and we
sat down and we're
just having chips and queso and trying
to figure this out I would tell you
don't do this
you're going to carry 700 000 of debt
into you the rest of your life
you don't have a way to pay that anytime
soon
and you know I I don't want to sign you
up for debt to die debt till you die I
don't want to sign you up for that
um and uh so I I guess I get to play the
part of dream killer here because I
don't I think your dream I'm afraid your
dream is going to turn into a nightmare
now if you were to do this and I'm
telling you I would not do it
I'm gonna ask you please don't for the
sake of your family and your kids the
stress that 700
000 is going to put on your soul that's
61 years old 121
000 It's Gonna Take Years off of your
life and so uh it's gonna be more of a
nightmare than a dream When the Smoke
Clears the only way to do it is just to
buy the land and uh with a construction
loan and build the house and you're
going to put 200 000 down out of the
sale of your current house and the
seventy thousand dollars that you have
in an account so you're gonna put 275
000 down
um on the deal and um
in a construction loan then on the how
on the land also as First Mortgage
position on the land is the only way
they do them they don't do a land loan
and then a construction loan they don't
do that construction lenders want first
position they don't want to be behind
the land loan so they're going to take
out the land loan and roll it into the
construction owners if you do a land
loan that's what's going to happen so
ever told you to get a land loan don't
know what the flip they're talking about
if you're going to build a house
because you're going to end up with a
construction loan to put the house on
there and they're going to pay off the
land in the construction loan because
they want first position then the whole
thing is going to roll into a permanent
final mortgage a conventional mortgage
15-year fixed on 700 000 is not going to
be a fund payment to make
on um
you know 120 000 a year it's not it's
not going to be a joyful thing and if
you flip that around Dave and you say
what do you say he has 200 left to pay
off this house he's got two hundred
thousand in equity when he sells his
other house we still got 300 left to pay
and then he's got
um yeah and he's got 75 in cash so 275
is the net cash that's going to go down
on this after he sells the house he's
currently in I'd love for him to sell it
and then them downsize get that sucker
paid off and then vacation like crazy
people yeah
yeah instead of go buy something else I
wouldn't buy this land yeah no chance I
I just you can do it if you want but I
you called me you made the mistake of
asking and we'll 100 love you enough to
tell you what we think we would do if we
were in your shoes please don't do this
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
earlier this week we announced our smart
conference weekend is heading heading to
the windy city that's right we're going
to be in Chicago
September 15 and 16 all the Ramsey
personalities me Rachel Cruz Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman George Campbell Jade
warshaw will be on the stage in Chicago
to help you change how you think how you
behave and help you manage your life all
the way around for better you leave with
a plan to stop doing stupid stuff with
money jump start your career prioritize
your mental health improve your
relationships in general if you go to
the smart conference you're going to be
smarter and you're going to be part of a
live recording for the smart money Happy
Hour podcast with Rachel Cruz and George
Campbell and uh this is a Friday night
all day Saturday event the uh there are
Platinum tickets super Platinum tickets
whatever else check them all out we got
only 60 tickets they're going to have
dinner after the conference is over with
me and all the Rams your personalities
pretty cool and just 60 of your closest
friends are very small intimate
Gathering but that's a super those
dinners get off the rails man those are
fun and those were super pricey tickets
too so the bottom line starter though if
you just want to come general admission
79 bucks this will be sold out very
quickly Chicago 15 and 16 of September
ramseysolutions.com events and get your
tickets now the Ramsey Show question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for home services for over 40
years neighborly has an exclusive
network of trained local service
providers backed by the neighborly Done
Right promise so if it's not done right
neighborly we'll make it right visit
neighborly.com today to learn more April
is financial literacy month all month
long teachers and students in classrooms
Across America are taking time to talk
about the importance of learning good
money skills so we have a student
question for our question of the day all
right today's question comes from Bryce
in New Mexico
Bryce writes I understand all the
information I'm getting from the
foundations and personal finance course
I'm doing at school but I'm still a
little scared of the quote-unquote real
world what mindset should I have about
managing money on my own that will help
me feel more confident
I'll let you handle the the the money
part of this about the managing money
but I think it's important we we have a
culture Dave that thinks we can think
our way to confidence
that we can stand in front of the mirror
and just chant things and they just that
suddenly our bodies are going to feel
more confident it's not true you gain
confidence by doing you gain confidence
by practicing by action by taking little
steps towards something and having
little tiny Pebbles of success on this
walkway and so I would tell you to start
making a small budget and stick to it
and when you stick to it for a whole
month
um stop for a second and note that and
be proud of yourself for it and then
move on a little bit further
well you're exactly right I mean this
this the self-esteem movement has kind
of gotten out of control in the last
couple decades it's like if you just
tell people you're wonderful you're
wonderful you can't add and you can't
read but you're wonderful well and you
know the origin of that right is they
they did those studies on the CEOs and
they said hey all these CEOs who've made
it have
they believe in themselves and so then
they try to reverse engineer that by
just telling a bunch of kids they
believe to themselves yeah but you don't
you don't have to really accomplish
anything but you could just randomly
believe in yourself which is dumber than
a rock I mean you can't have high
self-esteem if you can't do math and
read so you need to learn the skills and
the same thing's true what you're saying
you can't have confidence if you haven't
fallen and God you can't have confidence
until you've done something you can
watch other people write a book ride a
bike you can uh watch a YouTube how to
ride a bike but until you ride a bike
you don't have confidence you're not
going to have confidence and until you
fall over and scratch your little hands
you're not going to learn to ride a bike
and then get back up all of that to say
um it's normal
and we're not putting you down at all
for feeling scared actually that's kind
of wise I'm glad because you're saying
gosh this is something I've never done
before so it's a little scary I'm
insecure about it I don't have false
confidence because someone said ta-da
confidence no nobody did that doesn't
work and so instead what you're gonna do
the trick I would tell you to do though
is
um in spite of being afraid go and do
the hard things but that's on one side
of the equation is don't be paralyzed by
it on the other side of the equation is
though don't act like there's no um
that there that there's no consequences
right so risk is real you know back in
my generation they would say don't bite
off more than you can chew
and so that's what happens when someone
calls here and they've got a 750 car
payment and they make a thousand dollars
a month they bid off more than they can
chew my day it was
don't let your mouth write checks that
your uh butt can't your body can't cash
that's right yeah and that wasn't the
word we use exactly yeah so there you go
and so uh yeah that's exactly that's the
same same thing though it's confidence
it's confidence and so David did not
walk up and slay Goliath he first killed
a bear
and a lion so by the time he came
against the giant you know what he was
doing he actually had skills that were
proven he was not just a cocky out of
control too much faith and no skills uh
God told me he didn't do that he just
walked up there and said yeah God told
me but I know I can do it because they
said you know you're gonna go out there
and get killed and he goes no I'm not a
killed a bear and a lion I know it looks
like this guy's who's this uncircumcised
Philistine you know and that's that's
what he said right and so uh it's the
same thing it's confidence based on
actually having done stuff and uh that
so that's how you fix it take little
steps to gain confidence and competence
both and the more competent you become
the more confident you will become and
the less fear you will have because your
fear is well founded absolutely good for
you man and I can imagine you're in high
school and all this this info is coming
at you and all these questions these
questions and and lessons it's a lot man
so good for you yeah there's there's not
an app
for your life you have to go live it
there's no there's no there's no
shortcuts there's no click on it on your
phone and it's all okay
you know it does you got to go do it and
that's that's the you know the downside
of having a magic wand in your life in
your hand your whole life Mary is with
us Mary is in Oklahoma City hi Mary how
are you
hi I'm doing well it's an honor to be
talking to you you too what's up
is uh are
I buy myself a car that we've been
saving up for for about four years
and so you have the money in a car
account that you saved the money for the
car
yes
okay how much is in your car account
uh we
in your car account
okay how much is in your emergency fund
our emergency fund has 36 000. in
addition to the 48.
okay and how expensive a car are you
wanting to buy
well the dealership oversold us and it's
going to be about 57 000. 57 000. well
hold on they thought you said you had
48.
what do you mean they oversold you
well
ask car for about six months now and one
finally popped up and walk away it was
walk away don't do it walk away you
can't afford it don't do it you don't
have the money
mm-hmm I know I know I know just don't
do it don't do it we've been working so
hard for it I know I know what's your
household income
166. okay and what's your net worth
say
found the house
what's the house worth the house is part
of your net worth
okay so you're millionaires
okay so you can afford to buy a car
that's fifty seven thousand but I don't
think you want to buy this car there's
57 000 I think you want someone to tell
you that you're getting screwed
they mark this thing they oversold you
what's that mean they mark it up over
sticker
well it's a trim level higher than I
wanted
oh okay okay what kind of car is this
Toyota Sienna we've got a two-year-old
son and uh one on the way
Corolla will do just fine no I mean uh
Sienna's the van right yeah
correct that's a wonderful car 57
000. okay
um so no I mean you just haven't found
the car that you want yet
because you have a 48 000 budget to buy
a car and you decided that right and you
know they didn't oversell you you almost
over bought you almost over bought you
don't blame them Highlander you can get
a Highlander for 45. they're great or go
buy a slightly used one one of the two
you I'm okay if you got a million dollar
net worth buying a new car as long as
your total of all your cars doesn't
equal more than half your annual income
this one's forty eight or fifty and
um your income's 166 so as long as the
other car is not more than 30 you're
okay doing this deal but not this deal
because you don't have fifty seven
thousand dollars
you just you
you got to say no and go do what you
want to do and not what they want you to
do
[Music]
all right
foreign
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions right on the debt free stage
is Cody and Emily hey guys how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
where do you live
Reynoldsville Pennsylvania cool welcome
to Nashville and how much debt have you
guys paid off
um
138 291 dollars and three cents
excellent how long did this take five
years and 11 months five years 10 months
23 days all right and your household
income during that time range it started
out at 71
835.35 to
687.19 or 16 cents what do y'all do for
a living bro you killed pennies man all
right we would uh sorry um I'm a child
care provider okay I'm uh
mechanic for the Department of Defense
and army reservist okay thank you for
your service wow what kind of debt was
this hundred and thirty eight thousand
it was
um
30 40 000 was her student loans and then
98 000 was our house you paid off
very cool what's this house worth
um I'd say 150 okay excellent excellent
good for you guys well done thank you
how old are you two 36 yeah and I'm 34.
and you have paid four house yep none of
your friends that age do nope nope
that's Pretty stinking cool yeah way to
go guys all right what happened five
years 11 months ago they put you on this
Ramsey stuff
um we got married in 2015
um my mom she got us FPU for a wedding
gift and then um
that was yeah 2015 and then
we didn't get FPU until 2017 and I oh I
just sat around for two years uh
[Music]
and when she first gave it to me I'm
like
great gift uh thanks yeah I really
appreciate that
um but then I started talking to guy at
work and then he said there's a radio
show so I started listening to the radio
show I worked at uh as an outside
salesperson so
I would um get in the truck and I'd turn
on the radio station listen to you and I
started making sense
um and I came home and told it to her I
said this sounds like maybe we should do
this what'd you say Emily I was really
negative
I wanted nothing to do with you honestly
why how come I just it didn't sound like
it would work she I was just not even
open to it at all and she asked she had
her own way of doing a budget she did
everything for us she still does
everything for us uh but she had her own
way and I said I need to start getting
in on this
um
so I said here's the every dollar budget
app she said no I have this I said but
this way we can both look at it and we
can be on the same page and uh so
fighting and fighting about stubborn
yeah my way is always better than his
his is always better than mine so what's
wrong what got you around Emily
um after the first class or two I would
say oh you went to the class Yeah we
actually went okay yeah 2017 we started
going so you started seeing that you
might you thought it might work after
all yeah I only went to the class
because it was gifted to us yeah and
because he wouldn't shut up about it
yeah Cody are you are you are you a
schemer do you always have a plan like
hey what if we do this she's like yeah
yeah I'd say so so this sounded like
another Avon hey honey we're gonna sell
essential oils and except this time it
was Dave Ramsey right yeah yeah but then
you get in the class you start saying it
for yourself yeah right very cool very
cool how's it feel to be completely free
at 34 36 years amazing it feels great
um we was it worth the sacrifice oh yeah
absolutely
um we so our journey was we did you know
the baby steps um baby steps too
uh we got finish up in 2000
18. it was February 2018. Emma was born
um
and so we were saving up we weren't we
weren't uh putting in monthly payments
we were saving that up and Emma was born
nothing nothing medically was wrong we
smacked it down on there and we were
consumer debt-free yeah and then uh we
went to three four five on the rest of
them and then last year uh beginning of
last year like we got like 60 000 left
on our house
I said we could kick this out in a year
a little over a year so I started
working
all those apps you can download on your
phone you know Uber all that good stuff
grocery delivery was a big one for me
um that made me money but uh I would
leave at 6 30 in the morning
um
I wouldn't get home until like 11
um because I'd be out there Emily you on
board with all that it was rough but it
was worth it you can see the house
getting knocked out right and now he's
home and we have them every evening
every weekend now Emily's like okay so
people probably need some groceries
delivered yeah
it was it was rough fair for a little
bit
um there was a
and July I was just worn down like man
this is
is it just one year of my life I can get
this done and never have to do it again
um
it was a nice sunny day out the kids
were out playing and
Cody we call him fella
um Cody Jr
he said dad you got to go back to work I
said yeah I got to go back to work he
said why and he was all sad and pouting
on the seat there I took I snapped a
picture with my phone and said this is
why I'm doing this so it's awesome so I
never have to do it again exactly yeah
way to go guys congratulations very
proud of you what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
I'd say um
doing a budget
working together you have to be on the
same page yeah make a make a goal well
first Dream have that dream this is this
is our Dream right here well my dream
she might not be her dream but just be
standing right here yeah wow this is my
dream so make that dream and then create
that goal and work towards that goal
very cool good for you guys
Emily what do you what do you tell the
husbands and wives out there that are
just rolling their eyes when their
spouse comes with another scheme
open to it let's listen maybe even try
it a little bit
um you never know nine times out of ten
he's right oh well there's that you said
that like God
that's better that's better than me Cody
I'm not even that good yeah it's good
way to go celebrate that one out of ten
right that's right that's right hey
we've got the live and give bundle for
you the baby steps millionaires book
number one bestseller and you guys are
on your way to be millionaires uh The
Total Money Makeover book and of course
another Financial Peace University
membership you'll be able to give those
to somebody and help them on their
Journey or enjoy them yourself whatever
you need to do all right bring the
kiddos up and tell us their names and
ages this year's Emma she's five this
year's Cody Jr we're calling him the
fella he's three and that's Colton 17.
all right way to go guys very good stuff
excellent excellent work all right it's
Cody Emily Colton Emma and Cody Jr and
138 000 paid off house and everything
five years and 11 months making 71 to
121 lots of extra hours got her done
completely free at 34 and 36 years old
Pretty stinking amazing well done guys
all right count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go you
man I'll tell you what if you're out
there wondering if you can do it you can
do it you can do it it's painful when
your little one looks at you and says
daddy why are you leaving for this that
was I've never even heard that or
thought of that that's that's that was
why I take a picture and I'm gonna keep
this thing close to me so I can see it
that's why I'm doing this I remember
later yep that we paid a price to win
that's right and uh it wasn't it wasn't
a decade of overwork one year it was one
year one year and we're free we're free
free never have to do it again
so the weird thing is if you don't do it
right you get to do it over that's right
that's right
but now you can get all the baseball
games yeah all the dances you can go to
all the rehearsals don't miss a thing
you can be a dad this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
scripture of the day Proverbs 22 29 do
you see a man skilled in his work he
will stand before Kings he will not
stand before obscure men
Calvin Brodus Jr AKA Snoop Dogg said
it's flipping hamburgers if it's a
flipping hamburgers at McDonald's be the
best hamburger flipper in the world
whatever it is you do you have to master
your craft
it's true it is amazing if you become
the best at something uh whatever it is
you see a man skeleton his work he will
stand before Kings I struggled at uh
Fielding ground balls as a kid I was a
good pitcher and I was a good hitter but
I struggled with feeling ground balls
and I remember at a young age my dad
said if you can hit they'll find a place
on the field for you and there's this
like if you will focus on something and
get really really good at it you'll
stand before King they'll figure it out
for you that's right Alex is with us in
Norfolk Virginia hi Alex welcome to the
Ramsay show
yeah thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
if I had a uh interesting question I
guess where to where I should be
allocating uh where I'm putting my
investments in
um so I have a I'm in the military so I
have a tsp that I've been doing 15 and
two and then I've had an IRA that I've
had that I haven't really added because
I've been through the PHD which is wrong
both from uh Roth and then I had a
taxable account that I've been uh also
putting money into in addition uh with a
thought process of thought process of
that being uh like a down payment for a
house at some point I don't know when
that would be good
um so I just didn't know should I
because I don't I do plan on getting out
of the military in about two years
um apparently working on my degree so it
should be better since I'm transitioning
out to put that in the ira
um
doesn't matter yeah I mean the only the
only advantage of the Roth IRA would
have over the Roth tsp is you might have
mutual funds that would outperform some
of your tsp selections
by far the C plan in the tsp is the best
we tell folks to put 80 in that 10 in
the S and 10 percent in the eye
don't do any of the auto adjusted
garbage
yeah okay just just pick C for most of
us C out is a common stock plan it
models the S P 500 and it outperforms
everything else in the tsp Spades all
over the place
they asked a small company and you just
the only reason I'm putting 10 in there
is because it's really volatile it's up
and down but some years it has an
incredibly Good Year the I is the
international the only reason I'm
putting some in there is so you don't
have all your money in the US economy
only in terms of your Investments and so
uh I'm trying to model based on the the
production of those funds or those
indexes in there uh you know what we
would do otherwise now if you go out
into a smartvester pro and sit down you
don't get a match do you
uh it's a five percent okay you got to
do that before you do anything
because five percent free money is free
money you're gonna do that I'm assuming
you're debt free and have your emergency
fund in place right oh correct yeah good
okay all right we were talking like we
knew we were on the same page I'm making
sure we were all right so you're doing
great man how old are you
I'm uh about the 220. 20. what
what branch of the military are you
serving
thank you not a coast guard trainer
sitting out here in the lobby
yeah I was just talking to him at the
break yeah he's in town doing that so
very cool okay so Alex thanks for your
service hey this is going to be hard and
it's going to be counter-intuitive for
you
um this is the easy part for most of us
Immortals
is you're going to have to make peace
with doing the same boring thing over
and over again for a long long time
you're a go-getter you go knock stuff
down you plan way ahead and you're gonna
have to just make peace with
I'm gonna put 15 this account the rhythm
of automatic yeah yeah it's boring dude
it's boring if you do that you're gonna
be on man you're so cute way to go man
I'm so proud of you that is excellent
excellent stuff very very well done yeah
I I would make sure I get the match 80 C
10 that's 10 I and do that the tsp in a
Roth and uh then if you want to do
something outside with your smartvester
pro if you want to put some of your
money over there to a total of 15
between the two then you might get four
Mutual Funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international
uh that that grouping would outperform
the CSI you should be able to actually
get funds that do outperform those but
that's not going to be the secret the
secret is that you're freaking 20 years
old and you're brilliant you are the
secret sauce of success in your life it
is you know what to do and you're not
you're not gonna mess this up Joyce Is
With Us in Phoenix hi Joyce how are you
I'm fine
I do a question I'd like to have to
comment on
the housing market here
looking to sell our house in the next
five to seven years
probably several times a month we had a
postcard in the mail offered to buy your
house for cash it's correct don't do it
okay can you explain why yeah because
it's people doing flips that went to
some Tick Tock uh real estate class and
they're trying to buy a house at
wholesale and flip it for retail it you
can get a lot more for that house if you
put it on the market with a traditional
high octane high protein realtor and
sell it retail to a family that wants to
live in the house because investors have
to buy Below Retail in order to sell it
at retail make a profit I did it for
years
okay there's nothing illegal or Nothing
Even scummy about what they're doing
they're just trying to buy a house cheap
I bought a lot of foreclosures back in
my 20s I bought a lot of estate sales
back in my 20s I went to auctions back
in my 20s because in every case I'm
trying to buy a property cheaper than it
was actually worth so I could sell it
for what it was actually worth and
that's what they're doing
makes sense
does that make sense to you thank you
okay that's how it works so yeah I get
those cards too by the way everybody
does I guess everybody's got a mailbox
gets them probably
so I think that I think you should
answer one Dave I think that'd be
hilarious
well then I'd have to have the guy come
tomorrow
I just think it'd be funny it's like
sure man come over to my house I just
because I don't have enough to do that's
it yeah
Jennifer is in Austin Texas hi Jennifer
how are you right quick before we run
out of time hurry up good what's up real
quick question we have two homes one we
are renovating we carry 265 000 on
second one we are living in while we
renovate it is
when we move out into our primary
residence is it more beneficial to sell
that secondary home to liquidate it and
put it all in mutual funds for
retirement
or to pay off our sell it and pay off
our Homestead and invest the rest
here's the thing when we've studied ten
thousand millionaires we found that the
typical path to the first one to five
million dollars of net worth is a paid
off home
personal residents and
mutual funds invested in good 401ks and
Roth IRAs and so I'm always going to
have the series of goals where you're
putting it baby step four you're debt
free with emergency fund in place
putting 15 of your income away towards
wealth building and retirement baby step
five is kids college and sixes pay off
the house early when you get the house
paid off then that takes you to baby
step seven there's nothing left to do
then but become very wealthy and
outrageously generous and you do that by
maxing out your 401ks and maybe paying
cash for some future real estate
Investments after that but your first
big hurdle is a debt-free personal
residence and be aggressively to the
tune of fifteen percent of your
household income funding
your retirement and your wealth building
if you'll do that that's the fastest
shortest correct way with almost no risk
towards building serious serious wealth
yeah I like yeah I just
can't wrap my head around paying a
mortgage on something
and uh
while I got the money sitting over here
something else to pay it off yeah yeah
it's just it seems it seems backwards
yeah
yeah and it it but it does but the call
it's the soul tax the culture that's
broke teaches you to do that right well
and I get if you want some noise if you
take a yellow pad and you write it down
and it's 10 return and I get six percent
here I can make four here there's just
that four percent is my sleep tax yep I
just want to go to bed sleep tax sleep
tax that's better than stupid tax
thanks
Ben James Zach and Andrew are the booth
dudes did a great job John you too on
the on the show that puts us our in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]